the llamas just want to be
fed their owners just want to know
what's going on
without warning they suddenly found out
that the government
didn't want people from outside bolton
visiting them
very confused really because some people
are obviously very wary of coming
visiting the farm this morning for
example i
would say we've had maybe 100 phone
calls
either people wanting to cancel their
tickets coming visiting the farm
or transferring tickets to a later date
updated guidance on the gov dot uk site
said the indian variant was spreading
fastest in bolton
and seven other areas so people should
avoid traveling
in and out of there the trouble is
no one in the affected areas seems to
have known that the guidance had
changed here like elsewhere people have
been traveling around
as normal like becky
and rhys who'd come from manchester i
really heard anything about it no
i think i think obviously we're aware
stuff's going on but i wasn't aware that
that hadn't come in and that was what
was happening
so yeah that's news to us i think i
still don't understand world can we go
on where can we not go
i just don't understand it we wouldn't
have hesitated today at booking
something outside of bolton
and i wouldn't have even known i was
doing anything wrong
the advice is clear according to the
westminster government
i'm surprised to hear that people think
this is uh
sort of come out of the blue it hasn't
it's about formalizing
on the record the guidance which we
believe people can and should follow
in order to make sure that we tackle the
not to have more spread of the
indian variant the local authorities
involved point out it
is simply advice and not illegal
in a joint statement they said following
the national coverage of recently
revised guidance
we have met with the national officials
and confirmed
there are no restrictions on travel in
or
out of each of our areas there are
no local lockdowns local lockdowns do
not work
we in bolton have had experience
first-hand experience and i'm going to
say disproportionately and unfair
first-hand experience
of local lockdowns they do not work
and i will continue to fight against
them
[Music]
people here are being asked to take all
necessary precautions
as the local hospital copes with a
growing number of
covered patients the government now says
they'll make their advice clearer
lisa dowd sky news bolton